hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wonderful game from last year's
fide World Cup um it's um now you guys
have been requesting more uh abdusader
of games and this is uh one that I
haven't shown in probably uh the game
was overlooked by many now due to the
fact that uh abdulsate lost his match to
vaseerbaijan
um the two classical games ended in a
draw and this is the first game of the
Rapids it's truly truly a wonderful one
and most likely why it got overlooked
but it's a spectacular game it features
two really awesome pause the video
moments so you guys will enjoy that and
sorry about uh misinforming you about
yesterday's uh uh world top 20 uh at the
moment when I was showing you the table
uh it got updated and then uh obviously
as it gets updated it gets messed up so
some of the players disappeared so Arjun
wasn't actually number 16 in the world
he was number 18 but I will show you the
actual one after we check out this game
so uh you uh you know uh you you don't
think that he just jumped you know 30
rating points out of nowhere so let's
check it out it's uh like I said
wonderful game uh really awesome to
pause the video moments Let's uh let's
do this so Abdul satro has the white
piece and he opens with E4 uh we have E5
by durability Knight to F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to B5 yeah goes for Euro
Lopez with A6 and the best shop captures
and C6 going for the exchange variation
which sort of isn't all that much for
white but uh I mean you've seen what
Bobby Fischer did with this not so much
for white so the characters we have
castles and now how do you handle the uh
E4 E5 Pawn being uh attack well you
could defend it with some like F6 you
could play uh you could pin the Knight
let's say Bishop G4 you could play Queen
to D6 but here we have Knight to the E7
it's a it's a cool way of defending the
pawn without actually defending it uh so
Abdul Sato accepts the challenge Knight
captures on E5 and now Queen to D4
similar as if white did not Castle but
now it's not as scary for white so of
course the Knight is attacked the pawn
is attacked Queen to H5 now threatening
Queen captures on F7 and G6 with Queen
cap so we have Knight to F3 uh offering
a queen trade uh but this is of course
favorable for white so Queen captures an
E4 uh adorable just wins his Pawn back
and now Knight C3 developing while
attacking Queen to F5 black wants to
trade Queens only on his terms Queen to
H4 uh
declines this trade and the bishop to G7
we have D3 and now Queen to G4 insisting
on the queen trade and now just Bishop
to F4 and at the time this game was
played uh this was a new move and the
position has never been reached again so
it is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game
uh and here A Dollar by the trades Queen
captures and H4 Knight captures on H4
and King to d8 now you have to defend
your C7 Pawn Knight back to F3 and now
Pawn to H6 uh we Rook after E1
continuing development and Rook FDA
biology does the same H4 preventing any
future g5s and the bishop to G4 now
developing and also threatening to maybe
ruin a white spawn structure so Knight
D5 attacking the bishop and the bishop
back to E6 we have knighted the E4 uh
and now Pawn to B6 preparing to shift
the king all the way to B7 and get the
Rook into the game so rookie two uh
maybe you're playing something like C3
to defend your video Pawn maybe Rook 801
the double up Rooks on the E file King
to C8 and now Knight the C4 and what is
the idea behind this Knight to C4 move
Ken black Play Bishop captures and then
Bishop captures well you could but uh
for one you're giving up your Bishop
pair and for two it just isn't all that
great for example captures captures and
Bishop captures on B2 there's this very
nasty Rook 88e1 with all sorts of
threats like Knight the D6 uh check now
with the Rooks doubled here it could get
very nasty for example if King B7 uh you
can just resign this uh for example
Knight D6 checks C captures Rook
captures here and that's pretty much it
you have a rook on the seventh rank
you're just gonna start gobbling up
pawns and this is lost for black
so after Knight the C4 we have Knights
the F5 by doorbelly now with somebody
else of maybe bringing the Knight to D4
but for the moment going after the H for
pawn and I'll just Rook 8 to E1 inviting
Knight captures on H4 and even though
this is playable it would take you too
much time to calculate all the ins and
outs and like I said this is a rapid
game so Rook the d8 says all right I'm
not comfortable with my Rook on E8 let's
just move it and now Knight back to E5
again asking are you maybe interested in
a nice H4 Pawn but then the C6 Pawn fall
so here King B7 defending the pawn and
now Knight back to F3 we have finally
Bishop captures on A2 you could play
Bishop captures on B2 also or you could
play something else but here Bishop
captures an A2 and this is a most most
interesting move uh that could be met
with some very uh clean Precision but I
have to remind everyone that this is
rapid and here B3 was played which is
not the best way to play this best way
is to play G4 Force the black to move
the Knight or uh to put something on D4
and only after let's say an ID for
Knight captures and Bishop captures now
you play B3 and now it's much much
different because now next move C3 will
come with an attack on both the Bishops
it's not a winning uh position for white
or anything uh White will still have to
fight very hard because black will have
a whole lot of pawns for example C3 now
we're gonna have to capture captures and
captures and the black has seven pawns
white has four so you have three pawns
for the uh piece and you also have
already the past the A and B Pawn so it
would be it would definitely be a game
white would be up a piece but black
would have three extra pawns okay after
Bishop captures and A2 we have the
immediate B3 barbosatro and now Ponte A5
uh saying that you will you are not in
time to trap my Bishop also Rook A1 is
impossible because the bishop covers
that square I know you guys forgot about
the bishop so Bishop to E5 uh contouring
this bishop and now just Bishop captures
Knight captures and pawn to A4 and now
any Rook A1 will just be met with eight
characters on B3 so B captures an A4
here you could also go for Knight
captures on F7 but it doesn't help white
all that much black is just better here
so B captures on A4 and then now Bishop
to E6 uh if you if you go after the pawn
then C4 and then the bishop really has
no way of returning into the game so
first the bishop back to E6 and now Rook
to B1 Abdul santro real is that he is
not better here and that he will have to
play for tricks and now of course The
Rook captures on A4 is impossible if you
do this then Knight to C5 would check uh
wins The Rook as of course the B Pawn is
pinned uh so after Rook B1 Rook to A5
putting pressure on the Knight but just
Pawn to F4 nicely defending Knight
captures on H4 WHAS it finally grabs
this pawn and now Pawn the C4 uh we have
G5 and now Pawn to C5 and now what is
happening here and what is the idea
behind this move well uh best for uh
vasif would be just to kick away the
Knight with F6 but he decides to kick
away this Knight with F5 and this allows
abdusato a really really awesome idea uh
to be pulled off and that is Knight to
D6 with check and now the problem is of
course if the Knight is captured then
the B6 Pawn is not defended but there's
no other move that you can play uh other
than this for example you move the king
you just get destroyed Knight captures
and C6 and everything just falls apart
if you capture the Knight C Captain B6
now B7 check the Knight covers uh these
squares it's game over so the Knight has
to be captured C captures and 6 and now
Rook captures on B6 with check King to
C7 this is the only move uh Rook
captures on C6 with check King Bank to
B7 and now even C captures on D6
preparing Rook to C7 check and also this
is a defense against The Rook captures
on E5 if black would play Rook captures
an E5 remove the defender of the C6 Rook
uh it seems like black is winning but
there's the uh solution to uh Rook the
C7 check and then you recapture King B6
Pawn captures here and now you just get
destroyed Ruby to check and so on you
have the two pass pawns uh this is
completely winning for white so C
captures on D6 we have King the A8 again
the only move to survive and Rook the B2
now and here you have to play G captures
on F4 with this move you are still in
the game however after Bishop to D5 the
move that was played uh there is such a
spectacular move that it was too much
even for Abdul satrov to find in a rapid
game however you guys guys as usual I
imagine are comfortable in your own
homes or maybe you know driving
somewhere you know watching this on your
smartphone uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find an absolute
instant resigner for black or rather a
winning move for white while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
spectacular move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to D7 that's right and there's no
defense here the threat Rook the C8
cannot be paired and or the only the
only move that black basically can play
is Bishop captures on C6 but now the
real idea comes to mind Knight captures
and C6 attacking the rook and there's no
move with the Rook once the the pawn is
captured this is just mating one and if
you don't capture for example you move
the Rook somewhere let's say you move
the Rook to h8 it doesn't help you then
you capture this Knight this Rook then
the pawn gets promoted it's uh
impossible to play this but again it was
too much for absor to find in a rapid
game he played Rook B to C6 because he
found a different idea and now uh you
it's it's still extremely hard for the
valley to hold this uh he played Knight
captures on G2 it's a terrible terrible
moment to grab a pawn because now Point
D7 and now King the A7 getting the king
away from the back rank but now Rook the
B8 seems impossible because the B8
square is defended twice but you kind of
want to trade if if black captures
captures captures captures you just get
a queen into the game and it's game over
so here after Rook the B8 Rook captures
and D7 was played during Valley has to
give up some material to eliminate the
past Pawn Knight captures on D7 and now
comes in Knight captures an F4 uh so uh
what's the situation here you can see
that abdusattro is now up the exchange
he has two Rooks whereas durability only
has one uh but uh there are three pass
pawns on the king side if vasive can
start pushing those could also be very
very interesting but of the satrov plays
it very clean Rook the C8 with the
threat of Rook the C7 this will be game
over so Knight the E6 guarding the C7
square and now just Knight to B6 and
what is what's the idea behind Knight to
C6 uh well during a while it says all
right show me Bishop the B7 attacks the
rook and we've reached the position from
the thumbnail I imagine I will be using
this for the thumbnail so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
This brilliant brilliant finisher while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on adding another
beautiful mating picture into your mind
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook to A8 with
check this is what uh uh Abdullah played
and he was in this position unmove a 43
that was if Dura barely resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here it's a completely forced variation
the only move you have is King capture
uh is Bishop captures because or all the
other moves are illegal and after Bishop
captures there's the wonderful Knight
the C8 with check and again all of these
squares are covered by The Rook so the
only square is King the A6 and now comes
Rook the B6 Checkmate so to pull off
this Checkmate you had to use everything
the weird placement of the bishop the
weird placement of The Rook uh you you
had to sacrifice it's something that if
you don't know it exists you might find
it in a classical game but you will not
find it in a rapid or a Blitz game but
now that you know it exists you will
also find it in your own rapid and Blitz
Games and Crush many opponents you know
playing online
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really really uh wonderfully
wonderfully done if you guys want to see
it once again it's a rook day 8 check
here this Knight to see check King H6
and Rook the V6 absolutely beautiful so
uh hope I hope you enjoyed it and to
rectify yesterday's mistake here are the
world top 30 now you can see that uh
Arjun irrigation is number 18 18
actually not number 16 like we've shown
yesterday uh something happened to the
uh to the Cross table I have no idea
what uh but yeah those are the top 30
and you can see that Abdu satrov also
joins the world's top 30 he is now
actually in in number 30 27 13 and we'll
see if he will be able to push this as
hard as gukesh and Arjun are pushing it
but it's truly truly a a remarkable age
that we are living in as these young
players are just uh you know breaking
into the the top 30 top 20 and uh well
Arjun even uh you know further than that
so we'll see we'll see what what
tomorrow brings or today but today is
the start of the singfield cup so I will
most likely be covering that but also if
the youngsters continue pushing hard we
will be covering that as well nowhere is
there uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it and the story about
tricking you yesterday it was not my
intention I would like to thank Uzi
Charlotte Frederick karager Petro
Gabriel Gerald watts and wood for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World like the
singfield cup that starts today thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day